russian president vladimir putin says he
has signed a decree ordering the partial
military mobilization of russia's armed
forces beginning today in an address to
the nation putin said reservists will be
drafted into the army to fight in
ukraine he said the aim is to quote
liberate the donbass region putin said
the west wants to destroy russia and
does not want peace in ukraine
to protect our motherland its
sovereignty and territorial integrity to
ensure the security of our nation and
people in the liberated territories i
consider it necessary to support the
defence ministries and general staff's
proposals to hold partial mobilization
in russia
i spoke to our moscow bureau chief
europe uh rochetto earlier now he's in
riga latvia after dw was forced to leave
russia just before putin's invasion of
ukraine and i asked him what this
partial mobilization means well this
actually is so-called partial
mobilization is exactly what was
expected and mostly fiat in russia it
means that only that man must go to the
front who are currently considered
reservists you have already served in
the army and are experienced militarily
moscow is talking about 300 000
reservists who are being called up
putin justified this decision by saying
that the west wants to destroy russia
and that the country must defend itself
however politically mobilization is a
very difficult subject the russian
president has once again brought nuclear
weapons into play he too uh
the responsibility for alleged blackmail
he has transferred to the west here to
russia must defend itself he says um
yeah according to putin
yuri what impact do you think this will
have on support in russia for the war
a mobilization is extremely unpopular
and it would change the mood in the
country completely i think it would mean
that the war would become a reality for
many russian families whether they
wanted to or not and i think the
upcoming referendum will be very
unpopular too because they would
certainly give president putin the
formal right and maybe a kind of the
moral justification to further steps
like renaming the special military
operation to a full-scaled war and
ultimately to hit those ukrainian
targets that moscow didn't dare to hit
so far and forth also even to threaten
with nuclear weapons less abstractly
what we have heard him from him today
do you think the idea both the idea and
the reality of mobilization
will affect um russian soldiers morale
on the battlefield
well apparently the russians have a huge
problem with the number of soldiers and
the main aim is to increase this number
as for morals um i don't think that the
mobilized reservists will increase the
fighting spirit so to say because they
are not volunteer fighters not soldiers
who know what they are fighting for
namely for money but people who have
been forced to fight and now putin has
to explain to them even better why and
for what exactly they actually have to
fight in ukraine i'm not sure that the
explanation he gave today on television
which now which which is not new uh that
this explanation is enough for these
people to be willing to risk their lives
in ukraine
yuri rashetto in riga thank you so much
for that